[inaudible] joining me today is the man
that I have dubbed the Willy Wonka of
politics. It even says so on
the back of his book right here.
Michael Malice. Welcome back to the
Ruben report. Get to be back again. Dave,
we have a lot to do, my friend. Uh,
now most of it obviously is going to
have to deal with your choice of wardrobe
at general persona and being,
you've really done it this time.
If I read this jacket,
pendant,
this is the actually the same
thing that Johnny Depp War,
but it's a w for him and that's an
m and now it's an m for Michael.
Although if you flipped it upside down,
it would be a w for William or
Willy Wonka. There you go. Uh,
that's actually the, the one that I didn't
see that one. It's not that either one.
What it is, it is the better one. Yeah.
So you're going to tell me the Charlie
and the chocolate factory with Johnny
Depp is better than Willy Wonka and
the chocolate factory with gene wilder.
And I'm not trying to be a contrarian
and I'm trying to block it.
If it's much better. I haven't seen it,
but there's no way it's better. Well,
it's pretty good. I'm telling you
how could it possibly be better?
You're telling me he was better.
He was better than gene wilder.
That's what you're telling me.
I'm in a position to make this call,
I suppose at some level because of the
great honor that I've bestowed upon you
by calling and either Willy
Wonka go out, but I just, I mean,
I just don't think anything could possibly
be better than gene wilder as Willy
Wonka.
Watch it and tweet out the answer.
This is a really disturbing start to
this thing. Okay, so let's do this.
So first off,
I'm going to do this interview completely
in a different way than I've ever done
before, which is that you may
notice I have no notes here.
Now my policy is that when it's a good
interview, I don't have to look down once,
but I thought,
you're so bananas.
Your political theories are so out there.
I thought I'm just going to sit down
and completely see what happens.
I am literally not going to write
down one thing beforehand. Uh,
so the reason that I call you
the Willy Wonka of politics,
he's not just because of your,
uh, high fashion style. Yeah. Uh,
but you actually do strike me
as a unique political thinker,
which is pretty freaking rare these days.
That's a huge compliment. Thank you.
That's all I have for you.
Okay. Good shot. Let's got
to know. All right. So, but,
but you really do. And even the way you
tweet, the way you use trolling, um,
you know, you're, you're out
there, political thoughts,
all of those things. I mean,
the way you present yourself, it's all
like just this really bizarre package.
So for people that didn't
see our first interview,
just give me Michael Malice one o one.
Let's just get the history
out of the way and then we'll,
then we'll go into the new right. And
the topics of the day, the Glib answer,
he sees the ball. You hate to
love. Uh, the longer answer is,
my background is with North Korea
was my last book with your reader.
The New Right happen as a consequence of
so many of my friends who were in to a
trolls who are anarchists fell down
these rabbit holes of what they were,
what was called at the time and he
and reaction and later became like the
outright and dark enlightenment.
So I watched the scene from build up from
the ground floor and then to have it
culminate to some extent in the Trump
presidency and contemporary cultural wars.
I had a bird's eye view so I knew
someone was going to have to write a book
about the subculture.
And I also knew that you know,
any reporter is not going to be able to
understand the scene cause at the very
least they're going to
be an outsider secondary,
they're going to have
their own prejudices.
So since my job had been to make North
Korea, you know, before I started,
when North Korea work,
the idea was they're crazy and crazy
means I don't understand you. It does.
It can mean, I don't understand
your can mean that your random,
but now everyone understands
North Korea is not crazy.
They have a very coherent logical
approach to their evil dictatorship.
And the same thing with this
scene. Everyone would like
to dismiss it. Jump ever.
Just loved everybody in. They're
all nuts. They're all Nazis.
And it'd be really convenient if you
could paint everyone with the same brush.
They'd be a lot less efficacious.
A, it'll be a lot easier to dismiss.
But that's not the way it is. And people
understand that any subculture, even the,
you know for the Republicans,
they think, oh the less the same,
the Hillary Clinton hate the Bernie
people, they really hate them.
So there's a lot of different
groups in what I call the new right.
And often though they're United in what
they regard as their oppositions possess
for progressivism between them,
they do not have much agreement.
Okay. So with that as the
backdrop to all of this,
and this also explains why when buzzfeed
and Huff Po and vox and the rest of
them are writing about you guys,
whatever that collective things here,
they always get it all sort
of wrong because as you
said, they're not part of it.
So they just look at the,
Oh, they must be racist.
Well, they also have an agenda. Yeah.
So racist means that which
is against progressivism.
And I have a list in the books of
things that have been called racist,
which includes moving into
minority neighborhoods and
moving out am I never did
in our neighborhoods.
Noticing races and not noticing races.
Milk a certain time of
dinosaurs. I mean picnics. Wait,
what type of dinosaurs? Racist. Uh,
there was the, in Jurassic Park,
one of the dinosaurs was called racist.
Uh,
I'm not sure exactly why I didn't follow
up meeting through the article. Yeah.
So I dunno. Um, and possibly a, um, um,
what's that? What's his name? Fred
Flintstones. Pet. Oh, Dino. Yeah,
he's a bit of a white supremacist. Just,
just [inaudible]. It's unfortunate. Um,
so I thought someone has to write
this book. And also it's a dark space.
So I wanted to have people be able to
explore it in an interesting way and in a
nonthreatening way.
Okay.
So for people that know nothing about
this and the couple groups that you just
mentioned, they are dark and light
and mint, the troll community,
all of this stuff. Can you just kind of
break down all of it? How did this start?
How did you even start caring about it?
Were you part of it?
What the Hell is going on?
I was on, cause even for me,
and I have some basic
understanding of this stuff,
I'm actually not totally clear on all the
sort of markers and where everybody is
online and all that.
So it starts, I grounded in, uh,
1992 when Pat Buchanan who is
regarded as a paleo conservative,
we teamed up with Marie Rothbart who
was regarded as a Paleo Libertarian.
So between those two men,
you basically have everything that
is happening today within this scene.
Meaning nationalism, a
trolling, flirting with racism,
um, you know, contempt for authority,
skepticism toward the establishment.
The two of them had many disagreements
and at what point, you know,
Pat Buchanan and turned on Murray Rothbard
and later he asked Murray Rothbard's,
um, executor for
forgiveness, literally, um,
getting on his knees and
asked me for forgiveness. I
broke that news in the book.
And that has come down to contemporary
terms where the Internet with social
media allows, and this is both a positive
and a negative, is back in the day,
if you were that one person in your
town with these rude fringe views,
you're the freak.
But now that one person with their weird
fringe views in that town can talk to
the other person with the rouge printer
using the other town or in Denmark or in
Asia, or can put on a purple jacket
and show up at the Rubin report.
It's all very busy. They can't pull it
off. Um, uh, you have to earn this jacket.
So,
but now they have a community
and discussion and they
can develop an ideology.
So what I saw happening as a result of
hanging out with the trolls is people
falling into this group called what was
called at the time near reaction or the
dark enlightenment. And it was things
like we need to return to monarchy. Uh,
America is this decadent Weimer Republic
that's on the verge of destruction and
where was this happening on the
Internet? So I'll need to know. I know,
but like where,
what do you mean w forums chat exactly
for him through all these blogs. You know,
it's very HP Lovecraft things you're
not supposed to know. It's especially,
it was, it was blogs, uh, not really
Twitter at the time and Facebook groups.
Those are the big ones back then.
So this would have been about like 2013,
2012. Okay. So now some of this
stuff starts bubbling up, right?
And you start seeing these communities
that sort of don't really align but have
some weird touchpoints. And what do
you make of those touch and, well,
what I knew from my, you know, I'm
a big pop culture person obviously,
and I knew how culture develops,
which is it starts at the fringe with
the Weirdos and then the edgy people,
the cool people like, hey, have
you heard about this thing?
Then it becomes more mainstream and
then like kind of the nerds get it.
Then the corporations appropriated
and kind of tone it down, right?
So all of the intellectual momentum I
saw on the right was a result of this
stuff. These are the people talking
ideas, both nefariously and positively.
These are the ones asking the
big questions and basically
the radical questions.
And one of the big differences
between conservatives than you,
right is this conservatives take what
is given and this isn't a slight against
conservatives and regarded as all right,
basically what we have, how do we fix it?
Then you write often has
a more radical approach.
Meaning just because something exists
doesn't mean it can't be destroyed
completely and started from scratch.
So these are two different approaches
and we see it regarding the press.
I got into an argument with Sean
Davis who writes for the federalists.
And his whole point is that, you
know, the media, they're all there.
They're all dumb. And my point is none
of these people are very, very bright.
And if they're all making the same
mistake in the same exact way,
that is not a function as to petty stupid
people are all going to agree this is
a function of something more nefarious. So
that, so it's not a bug, it's a feature.
Correct.
Because they're,
they do have a certain specific agenda
and everyone has a certain specific
agenda. So this is a big
separation between conserves
and you're right, is this a,
uh, you know, part of society
salvageable or is it inherently, uh,
impure and,
and beyond redemption?
So when Trump was being elected ahead,
Eric Weinstein sitting in that seat,
and what I said to him was,
what most people seem to want
is a panther in a China shop.
We know something's wrong with the system,
but we don't want to blow up the system.
We want a panther to walk in there
and knock something off with its tail.
And Bang one thing off with the Ted,
but then closed the door
behind it and we'll, you know,
a couple things we'll have broken,
but we'll be okay.
But there's no such metaphor as a,
a panther to try and copy.
It's a bull in a China shop,
but you just can't get it.
I sense that a lot of what you're talking
about is these people want the bull
in the chain. No, these people
want a bomb in a touch on the shop.
They want the China shop to be destroyed.
And the phrase China shop is pretty apps
here because it's talking about foreign
influence in America and that's China's
not their big villain specifically.
But basically the idea like this
store needs to be torn down.
We're not breaking some dishes this we're
way past the point of breaking stuff,
but they want to blow up the
whole store to [inaudible].
It's not just about breaking
the China that's in the store.
They actually want the entire
structure and to change
and salted the earth. Yeah. To make
sure nothing can be built there again.
But so, so where, where
do you fall on that?
Because I sense there is this weird
thing of there's this weird thing on both
the left and the right,
the left seems to really want to destroy
the whole thing too in a weird way.
But then you're,
you're talking about people on the new
right that want to destroy the whole
thing. They wanted to destroy
it for different reasons.
But what do you think the
left wants to destroy?
The left wants to destroy capitalism and
they want to destroy the basic way our
democracy has functioned
and things like that. Yeah.
Uh, I don't, I don't know that
they want to destroy capitalists.
And what should they think of it as
something that can milk and harness? Um,
Bernie, even Bernie, you
know, has said, you know,
vaguely positive things to
say about capitalism, but,
and I don't know that
they would ever admit.
Well, I think it's a slow,
it's a slow slope to get there.
You don't just come out with day one
and say you want to destroy capitalism.
You just keep right.
But undermining it over election after.
I agree with you, but what I'm saying
is then you write is saying, yes,
we want to destroy this chapter for
this book is called the case against
democracy.
So in the scene there is a huge
question of how is it that democracy is
inherently good,
let alone inherently legitimate.
So lay out a case. Sure.
So the base, the, you know,
people say that communism works
in theory, not in practice, right?
Well that doesn't mean anything because
everything works in theory. You know,
theory means he practices how you
figure out something actually works.
Democracy is one of the few things
that doesn't even work in theory.
And here's why.
If you have with,
they talk about voter
turnout being a good thing,
well at what point does it become
legitimate? If 70% of people vote,
they can speak for the 30% who don't vote.
What if it's 40% vote in 60%?
Don't at what point it that you can say,
this group of the population can dominate
this other group, uh, who haven't voted.
That's one example. But even
more technical terms, the purest,
I use an example from this book called
the Machiavellians, the purest, uh,
exemplar of democracies. The town
hall, you have a bunch of people,
everyone's there to kind of speak their
mind, put their point of view across.
Even in the town hall, you're going
to have to have limits on time.
You're gonna have an agenda,
what issues we're going to discuss.
So even in the most
democratic system a moment,
you're going to have an elite
setting the rules and boundaries.
So one of the ideas behind the new
right is this theory of this old school
theory a hundred years ago called
the circulation. The elites,
meaning Hillary Clinton will always
have more in common with George W. Bush,
then she will have with the janitor,
and you can't get rid of an elite.
So much is replace it with another elite
[inaudible]. So this is a little bit of
the way game of Thrones ended, sort of.
I, I, I'm not, I'm not
right. Okay. Okay.
There's a funny moment at the end where
they're trying to figure out how to rule
and in the future, and one of the
guys says, well, what about democracy?
Let the people vote. And then there's
a moment where you're like, oh,
where are they going to end with
democracy? And then everyone laughs. Yeah.
Well isn't there was another new right
moment early on because didn't some
person hold up like a PCP,
a piece of paper that says you promised
them they basically ripped in left.
Right?
So this idea that the constitution is
somehow going to start working and save us
is another thing that
they're very skeptical of.
So what, what are you politically,
if you had to give yourself
I am label. Sure. I'm an
anarchist or that adjectives.
An anarchist without adjective. Yes,
sir. Explain the adjective part of me.
There's different schools of
anarchism. Yeah. Um, and I am more, uh,
there's an arco capitalism this and
[inaudible] and Arco. Communism.
I like it all. My point is essentially
is that government is not legitimate.
It cannot be made legitimate. And you
have to start with that recognition. Now,
some people think, okay, if you take away
government, everyone's going to be equal.
You're going to have wage
equality. Some people think, okay,
it's going to be hyper capitalistic.
Sure.
I'm a lot more comfortable defending
anarchy than I am defending capitalism or
communism or cynical.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So I think most people here
anarchist and they just think,
well I mean I say this all the time,
it's just you want to end up in Mad Max.
You just want sort of warring factions,
constantly trying to take each other
out and that there is no sort of social
cohesion.
There's no way to build big projects and
things like that because we don't have
something that sort of bringing us all
together that the government kind of
sucky. I mean a lot of people
think this is kind of Sucky,
but it's the best we got.
It's the best criticism [inaudible] are
actually descriptions of the status quo.
Meaning what you're
describing is the status quo.
You have governments who are trying to
take each other out. China has, you know,
hacked our systems. Russia, you
know, is interfering in our election.
So other right now nations have a state
of anarchy with regard to each other to
some extent.
Um,
what Anik is and would do it provide more
security because you wouldn't have to
have a government monopoly.
Uh,
the idea that you need the government
to kind of build a big project is really
not necessarily true.
Uh,
and if anything the government is probably
the biggest hindrance towards people
working together because they have to run
things through some bureaucrat who has
no accountability.
Okay. But wait, want, I want to back
up before we go to down that road.
So just break down in a couple of these
other groups that were sort of in this
trolling community.
And can you just explain like free for
someone of a certain age that really
doesn't even under,
that's not on Twitter and then not on
four Chan or wherever the hell is going on
or discord. Sure. Like what is
actually going on with the trolls?
Like what is the goal of the,
the older people actually
know trolling quite well.
Cause the example I use in the book,
the first trial was Andy Kaufman.
So Andy Kaufman, right? He was the great
troll of all gray trial of all time.
He was on taxi as Laca,
which is not what he's proud of stuff.
And he would do things like,
he had this character called Tony Clifton,
who was basically, it's like old
lounge singer and a pink salmon blazer.
And he'd come down and sing terribly
and just be rate the audience. And,
and one most trolling moment is
he had this, he was performing,
I think in Atlantic city. And
he says, oh, well, you know,
my wife died a few years ago.
And when I look at my daughter's eyes,
I see my wife come on out here,
honey.
And she sits on his lap and they sing
and her voice cracks any slaps her across
the face.
And it goes with all you're doing,
or I'm part of the audience is
booing. And he goes, oh, don't go.
You're just making her cry more.
Well, not only was in his daughter,
it wasn't even a child who is an actress.
So trolling correctly is forcing a party,
exploiting a party's weaknesses in
order to turn them into an unwitting
performer. So other examples of
this, there was a little kid,
it's a little autistic kid,
was on the late show in the UK or
Ireland and they asked him, Hey,
what do you want to do Huey Huey,
what do you want to do when you grow up?
And he goes, um, I want to fly planes
into buildings. And the guy goes, what?
He goes, I want to fly planes, the
skyscrapers. And he's like, okay,
if you can't do that,
what would you want to do?
I'll move to Iraq and be a terrorist.
Now it's this little 10 year old boy and
the host now doesn't know what to do.
I think he's put on the
spot that is trolling.
Now trolling is often used on the internet
to be like being a jerk. That's not,
to me a definition of trolling.
There's plenty of words for that and just
go into the cell and saying, you know,
you're this or you're that.
That's not clever. Trolling
is an art. So troll. Okay,
so how is it the Trump understood this?
Do you think that's because this is where
people say, well, he's just an idiot.
He just says whatever.
Free lunch. There's no filter
that Tara, Tara, and it's like,
if that really is the truth,
then everyone else must be hyper
idiots. You know what I mean? I just
can't accept plausible truth,
which perhaps,
let me give a great example of Trump
trolling. Okay. Again, trolling,
meaning you're forcing someone to
become a performer by exploiting their
weaknesses,
which it seems like now all the media
has become all with his enemies have
become the, he'd get them
to take any position on any,
here's the perfect example.
Yeah. For one year he's yelling at
Elizabeth Warren, take a DNA test,
take a DNA test, take a DNA
test. She takes it in secret,
doesn't even test for
native American blood.
It says she's at most 100024th
she releases it and she goes, Huh,
Mr President? I took the test and you
know what? He goes, who cares? Yeah.
So now she's made a fool of, he is not
at all engaging with her and she's left.
You can even hear the curb, your
enthusiasm, music playing as she talks,
and this moment has become a broken woman
as a consequence of his clouding her
so thoroughly. What is it about him
that you think made him understand this?
How did this guy understand
this psychological trick
or whatever you want to
scenarios, right? Scott Adams,
who I know you've had on risk,
describes the Lucky Hitler phenomenon,
right?
That somehow it's just he always manages
to say that what he needs to to upset
people.
The other scenario is like there's some
kind of rain man thing going on that he
just sees people's weaknesses.
He knows exactly what to say and despite
him themselves, they lose their minds.
Another example of this was I
think it was pixelated, both.
There's some Twitter account and they
made this fakes a screenshot from Michael
Wolfe's book fire and fury about
how Trump watches TV all the time.
And the staff at the White House made
something called the guerrilla channel.
And he talks to the gorillas on TV and
he says, oh, that goodwill is good.
And people are, and it was clearly
a joke. It was meant to be a joke.
People repeated this like,
oh my gosh, Trump is so dumb.
He talks to television like,
wait a minute,
you can think he's as dumb as you want.
You're telling me this man
who is 70 who's had a TV show,
doesn't understand that you can't
talk to gorillas on a screen.
But that is the level that he's driven
them to. So it's hilarious to watch.
And it's beautiful from the [inaudible]
perspective because he's diligent
organizing the political
process and the presidency.
So the reverence that people have for
the presidency has deadly consequences
because it allows them to get
away with things like war.
And if you think the guy in
the Oval Office is a clown
and that clown is getting
ready to send your kids overseas to
possibly die or possibly kill people,
you're going to be a lot more
skeptical. God, there's a lock there.
So you think it's the whole book worth.
If only if only someone would write
a book about this sort of thing.
There's a lot there.
So you think in an odd way,
his behavior is
delegitimizing the presidency,
let's say the office of the presidency
or more broadly government in general.
And you ultimately view that as a good
thing because you don't think that really
has legitimate power to begin with.
Right.
One of the big views of the Murray
Rothbard school is that the two political
parties are literally rival gangs.
And just like a gangster
has the nice rings and the
suits, they wear their suits,
they go to the Senate. But these are at
base murderers who are plotting, you know,
fighting with each other.
But it's in fighting. Um,
so anytime the mask is dropped and you
realize these people aren't stealing your
money, they're trying to control your
lives, they're causing massive, you know,
harm around the world often.
Uh, that's a good thing.
What's the ratio element that
comes out of all of this?
It's because for as much as I get a lot
of this and I like a lot of the trolling,
the good natured stuff
that's really getting the,
the people that I don't like to flip
their lids. Like I love all that stuff.
And then there's this
other piece of it that,
that strikes me as it's hard to tell it
or they just intentionally inflammatory.
Do they really believe this?
What kind of power do these people have?
Are they coordinating all of that? Yes.
Jared Taylor is the head race realist,
right? These are the people who you
racism as the most important issue,
the outright, and I interviewed
him for the, for the book.
I went to his house and you know,
even he was confused and
there's this great moment,
he's got this very weird accent.
He goes,
are you telling me these people
really believe this Hitler stuff?
Like he couldn't wrap it
and I go, yeah. And he goes,
the idea in this day and age that
Hitlerism would be a model for America is
simply fantastic. And I go, you
mean crazy, right? He goes, Oh yes,
thank you for the clarification.
So even in that group though,
they're the racists,
but he is your approach.
You then you have the people
who are full blown. Yes.
Well what does that mean?
So there are the racist meaning there are
just people who just full blown racism.
They just actually racist.
They want people based on the color is
going to have different laws or not be in
this country.
You are
correct.
And they say if you're not,
if you don't see that as the most
important issue, you're blind.
So I, you know, had to engage
with that, writing this book.
Then they're the ones who
are, everything's about the
Jews, the Jews, the Jews, you,
I was, I was in Charlottesville.
I saw everything happening.
I couldn't go to all the events because
my contact was told don't bring the Jew
to the party. I was not
wearing the blazer. Uh, but uh,
so there is this whole subculture and
they disagree with themselves and it was
important for me to engage with them and
express what their point of view is and
show how they're wrong.
Because what happens is when
you drive people to the margin,
it's like telling an,
especially when deal with young males,
it's like when you tell kids
if you smoke the principal,
your parents and everyone's going to
get upset and then you can't get a pall
mall fast enough.
So that the same thing here,
it's like if you talk to these people and
say certain things people you hate are
gonna get upset, it's like, sign me up.
So the point I make in this book is you
take one red pill, not the whole bottle.
Because once they realized that the
corporate press is often dishonest and has
an agenda,
they fall down this rabbit hole.
And unless someone grabs him
by the collar and said, yeah,
you don't have to go all the way,
uh, we, we can stop right here. Uh,
there are often lost.
So this is,
you would argue then the
reason why sensoring these
people in suspending people
on Twitter and booting people off Facebook
and the rest of it is actually the
worst possible thing that you could do.
I don't know if you become,
you just feeding it,
I don't know if it's the worst,
but if they're going to say there is
an elite agenda designed to drive us
underground and keep the truth from
coming out, now they have evidence. Look,
we're being blocked. They don't want
to hear the truth. So that is a,
and the fact that David Duke,
for example, is still on Twitter,
is very curious to me. And again,
with the Internet and technology.
So, wait, what do you
think that's about then?
Well, I think David Duke is a
very useful foil for the left, uh,
because when he endorses people at Keith
Ellison or Johana Mar, it's crickets,
right? But when he says something positive
about somebody else, like, oh my God,
David do about Trump.
Yeah.
I don't think he likes Trump too much
cause Trump all Trump the kids married
except for one marriage Jews.
So, you know, I, I it's, it's uh,
he's not that fond of the president. Uh,
everything's about Israel. David Duke. Um,
and I told him once on Twitter. So that
was a fun moment. You took out the Duke,
like I don't know if I, I know I did.
He's still there and that's the problem.
Like why is David Duke there while
people like Laura Loomer art?
I think that is very
odd, uh, um, a situation.
And you would say that really is just
because of the power dynamic within
Twitter or,
or within something bigger than,
I can't speak to why I'm not in the side.
Jack's mind Jack Dorsey's mind. Yeah.
I do think there's something here that's
not adding up and I think the more
transparency the better.
Uh,
and I think Jack and some level
would agree with that. Yeah.
What's your position on what to do
with the tech companies at this point?
Related to all of this in the
censorship and everything.
I think the solution is going to be just
like back in the day we had cupid and
now you have Tinder and and, and all
these other sites and they separate out.
You're going, there's no reason everyone
has to be in one site. So the more,
if Twitter wants to say we're a site for
progressive ideas, they have that right?
And,
and that's perfectly fine.
They're going to lose a huge market
share because when you drive out fringe
ideas, whether evil, fringe,
you're also going to be driving
out the good fringe idea.
That's where innovation happens.
So if you're going to have this
bourgeois middle of the road,
I don't want weirdness, uh, you're going
to lose the interesting people also.
So this is a very big double edged.
So then why hasn't this
problem been fixed?
There's enough people frustrated
with it all over the political map.
Good old classical liberals are just
as frustrated as perhaps more nefarious
characters and nobody has solved
this. But your frustration might be
a feature because they say, look,
we're obviously doing things right. We've
got Dave Ruben upset. So if there, uh,
if we live in a culture that's heavily
dominated by the progressive ideology,
so for them, if they are getting
certain people upset, they can say, hey,
we're doing our job.
Right.
The euphemism they currently use as
the quality of the conversation. Right.
So yeah, I mean this is the
most Orwellian thing ever.
Like you are going to be judging quality.
So it's, it's, it's a very, it's very,
and which is a very different
thing from free speech,
which is messy and ugly and, and, and you
know, often reprehensible. [inaudible].
How do you think that the new
right then is supposed to,
I know you don't like boundaries and you
don't like gate keeping in any of those
things,
but how do you think it anything,
I like gates. I'm a, I'm, I'm
not an inclusionist person.
I'm very much for freedom of association.
If I didn't want to talk to someone,
I'm not I black people liberally,
but how, but all right, so, but you know,
in a wider group outside of just
what's happening in your mind and your
interactions with people,
how do you think that this new sort of
group of people that are all over the map
politically, right? Um, how do they,
how do they keep the fringe people,
the truly bad people out of the way?
This seems to be the biggest
yes. That nobody's solving. Uh, the Pr,
I don't think you can
because technology has made,
it used to be you had three
networks, right? ABC, NBC, CBS,
and between the three of them, you
get the news. Then drudge came along.
I talking about in the book and the
networks, like he's a lot legitimate.
He's not legitimate.
He breaks one of the biggest
stories of all Todd Monica Lewinsky.
They didn't know what to do.
He still,
he's not legitimate and
illegitimate is like, he broke news.
Who are you to say he's now Jim.
And so this,
this orthodox idea of legitimacy has no
inherent meaning other than tribalism,
right? So once you have technology and
thanks to Twitter, Facebook, whatever,
everyone has their own Mike and there
are more and more mikes being built every
day.
I don't see how you're going to be able
to put that genie back in the bottle so
you just have to let it be.
Then you'd say there's just no option.
It's just is correct and you have to
engage with bad ideas if you want to
diffuse them because you're
not thanks to technology,
you're not going to be able to censor
anyone. Let me give you another example.
I have this in the book.
Let's suppose this is like 1990 right?
And you're having an argument
censoring books and one guy's like,
we need to censor books like mine. Calm
has bad consequences. Someone else like,
no,
you need to hear free speech.
I come from 2019 teleport
back in time and I say, look,
someday you're going to be able to
copy a book infinitely at no cost.
You press one button,
you send it anywhere on earth
at the speed of light for free.
I would sound like a lunatic,
but that is the status quo. Oh,
and also you could you say a magic word?
No, but orange and read it a password. Oh,
okay. Crazy person. That's the status quo.
And technology is only going to increase
more and more and more to empower the
individual at the expense
of big conglomerates.
It becomes cheaper and cheaper to make
your voice heard. Back in the day.
You'd have to be like, if you don't like
it, make your own network. Well you did.
Yeah. Now, now it's going to be, I
mean, we're still using their pipes.
I'm still dependent on, at least for
the moment on, correct. There's tech,
there's a great book called the goal
and the point of this book is what's the
goal there? Was to go for business
and he says to make money.
So how you do this is you look at the
pipeline from conception to production and
you look at what's
slowing up your profits.
So maybe you don't have
enough shipping boxes,
maybe you're not producing enough bottles,
maybe you have too much inventory.
So you gotta have more marketing.
Maybe youtube is not sending your
videos out to your subscribers, right?
So you look at what the issue
is, the bottleneck, you fix that.
Once that's fixed, there's gonna be
another worst thing and you fix that.
So Twitter in many ways is a rear guard
movement right now because people are
realizing it's paypal
and it's the banks that,
and it's the fact that
there's domain registrars,
those are the next three that people
are going to build alternatives to.
Cause that's where the banks are
shutting down accounts right now.
And that's what's being underreported.
So Twitter is kind of a little bit of
a distraction because you'll always be
able to make some rival to Twitter,
banking and paypal.
That's what's something
people have to look at now.
And do you think the right
people are looking at it, uh,
I think in your world or
are people looking at it?
I don't think this is
an ideological thing.
I think it's just some entrepreneur who
sees a market opportunity to be like,
paypal is being arbitrary and I can
compete with them on some level.
All it takes is that one guy and then
the battle was won and then it's going to
be another battle. It's
a, as some situation.